c'est un véritable mythe hobbies qui se
déroule actuellement dans l'univers du
sport
quelques jours seulement après les
révélations des fientes de sarah abitbol
ancienne patineuse artistique qui a
décidé de prendre la parole pour
dénoncer les viols dont elle aurait été
victime adolescente de la part de son
entraîneur c'est chaque jour une
nouvelle affaire qui explosent à la
suite des révélations de la patineuse
plusieurs de ses collègues avaient eux
aussi témoigné des violences sexuelles
subies de la part de ce même entraîneur
quelques jours plus tard c'est le monde
du foot qui était secoué par une affaire
celle concernant le président du club de
football d'angers saïd chabane qui s'est
retrouvé en garde à vue suite à
plusieurs plaintes déposées à son
encontre pour une série de l'agression
sexuelle qui se seraient déroulés entre
2014 et 2019
aujourd'hui c'est l'alpiniste yannick
vallençant qui chez morandini a dénoncé
les abus sexuels et moraux dont
plusieurs élèves en formation auraient
été victimes selon lui on a eu des
premiers signalements sur ce qui pouvait
se passer dans le secteur du ski sur des
pressions indues des professeurs qui
abuseraient de l'heure de leur position
le professeur pour solliciter des
faveurs auprès des stagiaires avant de
viser un établissement en particulier
j'ai eu des échos sur l'école nationale
de ski et d'alpinisme de chamonix dans
sa filière ce qui à l'époque selon une
enquête du syndicat interprofessionnel
de la montagne une douzaine de victimes
se seraient déjà manifestés autre sport
même ambiance une ancienne pilote de
motocross se dit victime d'agressions
sexuelles de la part de son entraîneur
déjà condamné au pénal pour viol sur
mineure selon elle malgré plusieurs
signalements de ces viols la fédération
avait préféré fermer les yeux une
véritable révolution dans un monde où la
peur de parler de se retrouver sur le
banc de touche est grande mais selon
vous etait-il possible de réagir plutôt
vendre ils l'annoncent nous a rejoint
merci mandrill merci
et donc tenues de sport l'omerta et
bernard laporte merci bernard ni de
sport 2007 à 2009
président de la fédération française de
rugby je vous le dis on va donner
d'abord les dernières infos parce que ça
pète de partout comme madiot bernard si
celle ci le beau c'est le bordel
ah oui oui non mais c'est vrai que c'est
il faut connaître la parole se libère
c'était une bonne chose parce que si on
en est là c'est que heureusement
maintenant la parole se libère parce que
on va en apprendre tous les jours
ah ouais là bravo à sarah abitbol bravo
isabelle de mes joueurs avaient commencé
à écrire un livre
mais il faut effectivement parler on va
on va dire un petit peu les solutions
parce que on parle de gagner mais c'est
pas gagné le sujet le sujet c'est
comment aider ces victimes et surtout
comment tourner sur le champ pour faire
en sorte que ça ne se reproduise plus et
il ya des mères de famille des parents
qui doivent nous regarder il a des
enfants qui dit vrai quelles sont les
solutions parce que le sport c'est
magique on a tous envie que nos enfants
fassent du sport
voilà et aujourd'hui on se dit mais
qu'est-ce qu'on va les amener aux sports
est ce qu'il faut rester avec eux les
stages pour vous dire que ça va être un
massacre personnes à vouloir aller en
stage avec avec voilà avec ses
professeurs
on va tous on va tous d'une psychose et
c'est une psychose terrible et ça fait
peur aujourd'hui encore la mère d'une
patineuse nadjma mahamoud championne de
france junior en 2014 accuse gilles
beyer de harcèlement sexuel et de
chantage en 2017
voilà donc ça continue j'ai ce matin
chez jean marc morandini sur ses news le
président du syndicat interprofessionnel
de la montagne a révélé qu'il a mis en
place une cellule d'écouté
il y à déjà qu'il ya déjà des
témoignages voilà puisque dans tous les
sports ça commence à péter de partout il
ya le cas aussi saïd chabannes le
président du club de foot d'angers sco
qui a été mis en examen hier soir pour
agression sexuelle
regarde selon nos informations les faits
dont est accusé side chabane sont
similaires il se colleraient à ces
jeunes femmes les plaignantes leur
touche les fesses les seins les parties
intimes sans leur consentement
tout a commencé avec une plainte déposée
en janvier par une salariée du club pour
des faits remontant à novembre dernier
puis les enquêteurs ont identifié deux
autres femmes l'une évoque des faits
datant de 2010 est tout décrivent des
scènes très intimidante et craignent
l'homme d'affaires industriels et
président de club respecté et réputé à
angers contacté l'avocat de saïd chabal
n'a pas souhaité s'exprimer
voilà alors je vous le dis ça c'est
encore un autre dossier oui juste dire
en préambule que faut penser aussi les
entraîneurs font rappeler comment que
l'énorme majorité des entraîneurs des
prédateurs parce qu'on a l'impression
qu'on les regarde tous bizarrement il ya
dès qu'il ya des chiffres des brebis
galeuses mais laisse un beau métier
quand même faire attention
alors bernard tu va nous donner ton avis
tu me donner des solutions aussi et y à
vendre il la noce qui est avec nous
journalistes et réalisateurs du
documentaire pédophilie dans le sport
l'omerta dans le documentaire que vous
avez réalisé mandrill qui a été diffusé
en décembre dernier on a vu des
témoignages terrifiant coudray ont
montré de trois on voit dans cet extrait
par exemple on apprend qu'un entraîneur
de tir à l'arc pourtant proche des
parents a abusé de deux élèves de 9 et
10 ans pour garde mon club des archers
d'armor les encadrants sont tous
bénévoles
dans ce cas il n'est pas obligatoire de
vérifier leur casier judiciaire
c'est le témoignage d'une jeune fille
qui va susciter les premiers doutes
elle raconte au dirigeant le
comportement ambigu de roland ils
réagissent tout de suite le pousser à la
démission et alerte le club du coup pour
prévenir envoyer un mail à la ligue de
bretagne dans lequel elle expliquait que
roland avait en effet un comportement
inadapté avec les enfants après quinze
jours d'attentes
il reçoit une réponse
déroutante de façon objective je ne vois
pas ce que je peux apporter de plus au
club dans vos échanges sur les points
évoqués et semble que ce soit plus un
problème interne au personnel qu'un
problème de ligue
alors vendre il alors il ya plein de
choses dans votre documentaire déjà ce
que vous pouvez me donner tous les
chiffres qui correspondent à été
chiffres qu'on a vu dans votre
documentaire ils vont vraiment
intéresser les téléspectateurs
vous allez voir ces chiffres sont fous
parce qu'on n'en avait jamais parlé
avant en fait avec disclose on a enquêté
donc on était trois journalistes ont
enquêté pendant huit mois
on a identifié donc on a travaillé sur
28 disciplines sportives
on a identifié 76 affaires et 277
victimes donc c'est un peu moins de 300
je précise bien que ce sont ces
résultats empiriques annoncé pas une
étude scientifique ni statistique
donc vraiment ça concerne tous les
sports auxquels on a pu s'intéresser et
c'est vrai que c'est l'ampleur c'est le
premier truc qui nous a vraiment surpris
tous c'est à dire que ça concernait tous
les sports des petits clubs des clubs
moyens et des grands clubs à tous les
niveaux des niveaux un peu les amateurs
d'un côté et aussi des professionnels de
l'autre alors juste vendre et pourquoi
faut avoir fait ce documentaire à
l'époque parce qu'on se dit pourquoi
penser à ça qu'est ce qui vous a fait
qu'est-ce qui vous a mis la puce à
l'oreille en fait j'ai bossé avec deux
journalistes qui s'appelle mathieu
martinière et daphné gastaldi qui sont
deux journalistes basée à lyon qu'ils
sont cons beaucoup beaucoup travaillé
sur les questions d'agression sexuelle
dans l'église est en fait ils se sont
dits à l'église on a pas mal enquêter on
s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait un
système de protection aussi c'est à dire
que par exemple un prêtre dont on sait
qu'il a commis des actes ou d'une
agression sexuelle
parfois l'église le déplacer le mettait
dans un autre endroit en france où il
n'avait pas de bertheaume fin il pouvait
recommencer en tout cas on connaissait
pas son passé et c'était cette intuition
a peu qui nous a poussés à travailler
sur le milieu sportif et c'est aussi un
peu ce qu'on a découvert c'est à dire
une sorte de système qui ne permet pas à
la parole des sportifs en tout cas des
victimes de ceux de se libérer alors je
voudrais montrer une autre image de
votre documentaire de votre enquête
c'est solide pauline une jeune athlète
de triathlon son entraîneur a profité
d'un déplacement pour la violer regardez
un début de carrière prometteur brisé
net par son entraîneur
un week-end on devait aller une course
sauf que au lieu de s'arrêter sur la
course il a continué la route et après
il m'a fait monter dans l'arrière de son
camion
il s'est passé quoi c'est à lire nos
formats c'est difficile de le dire mais
une fois dedans par contre la faune je
sais pas je pense que j'ai jamais dit
autant de fois le mot non dont aussi peu
de temps avec des gestes et tout ça
enfin après on est rentré chez moi il va
déposer chez mes parents comme
commission ne pas s'entraîner avant quoi
alors pauline à tout révéler à son père
qui immédiatement à porter plainte et
avertit le club et regarder ce que vous
allez entendre et complètement révoltant
pour le père de pauline il ne fait aucun
doute que l'entraîneur va être envoyé en
prison
il contacte immédiatement le président
du club pour le prévenir du viol présumé
de sa fille sa réponse est à peine
croyable
quand j'appelle dit là je suis pas
surpris de votre appel téléphonique
jeune homme était un petit peu que
norilsk problème là il me dit j'avais eu
des échos dans le domaine de cet
entraîneur in this vraiment pourri nous
prouve
voilà le père pense que le club va
réagir mais ils se trompent
finalement rien la famille s'estime
aujourd'hui lâché par le club de
triathlon
alors voilà c'est une arnaque de
nombreux un nombreux témoignages et à
maxime aussi voilà donc votre reportage
aussi avait un jeune homme maxime qui
était abusée sexuellement par son
entraîneur de ping pong et ce qui affole
on sait que cet entraîneur a été
condamné à la prison et à sa sortie il a
retrouvé un poste de coach auprès de
deux mineurs c'est ce qu'on voit
également dans le reportage alors on va
faire un petit tour de table après on va
parler des solutions et on va parler d
un témoignage voilà doudi de marie qui a
été victime d'abus sexuels de la part de
son entraîneur de 2009 à 2011 elle avait
14 ans louis gill alors depuis qu'on en
a parlé sur le plateau - ya des familles
qui m'ont contacté notamment pour une
affaire dans une ligue régionale de
karaté et pour une affaire dans le
football américain un club d'île de
france où un entraîneur vient d'être
condamné par le tribunal de pontoise et
tous les gens me disent on avait alerté
les clubs
on avait même pour cette alerté la
fédération mais la fédération parce
qu'elle craignait parce que sa
motivation c'était de ne pas perdre de
licenciés
et n'ont pas voulu nous écouter le gros
problème que pose la question est-ce que
vous flippez pour vos enfants parce que
c'est vrai ça ça fait peur mine de rien
voilà on se dit on a même tous de peur
voilà deux dira peut-être qu'on va
apprendre des choses on est on devient
on est une biopsie cause et même chez
les entraîneurs vous en parlait il ya un
instant les entraîneurs est aussi ils
vont avoir du mal aussi à faire leur
métier matin vous dira peut-être que
tout va être mal pris
donc là il ya un lien il va voir si les
hyènes certaine forme de gènes des deux
côtés et qui peuvent faire beaucoup
beaucoup de mal alors bernard inom à
chaque fois on entend le même truc c'est
ce qu'on a vu dans le reportage
l'excellent documentaire voilà co2 de
vendre il je vous dis on entend à chaque
fois les institutions ne bouge pas les
fédérations ne font rien pourquoi parce
qu'elles ont peur de perdre des
licenciés elles ont peur pour leur
réputation c'est ce qu'on entend
j'espère que c'est pas vrai parce que
c'est vrai que ces affichages end en
hausse à moi je suis président de
fédération française de rugby depuis
trois ans quand on est arrivé on a de
suite signé un contrat avec la fameuse
association colosse aux pieds d'argile
d'accord et le rôle c'était une demande
d'aller dans les clubs informé que ça
existe voilà de la vigie de la vigilance
c'est la première des choses
et s'il ya un problème nous alerter
d'accord c'est clair nous sommes trois
en dix sept cas 17 97 97 4 3 sur les 17
14 étaient déjà en justice et là le club
où les parents avaient attaqué déjà et
sur les trois autres c'est nous qui ne
sont pas suivis et qui ont dit qu'ils
ont dit au club il faut aller en justice
et sur les trois gamins qui a fait 18
mois ferme de prison et nous bien sûr
plus de licences c4d qu'il ya sa licence
suspendue jusqu'à la fin de la quête
et après quand il ya quelqu'un tombe au
pénal c'était docteur n'entraînera plus
jamais dans nos clubs parce que
effectivement quand on regarde tous les
sports souvent l'éducateur idée dans son
club d'attaché au tchad et je crois qu
encore une fois c'est ça qui est
inadmissible
est ce qu'elle est pauvre on est
ministre il ya eu des bruits vous aviez
der des retours de problèmes aux
différentes fédérations c'était un flic
qui n'était pas aborder parce que c'est
la question qu'on se pose apparemment
bien tout le monde dit on savait qu'on
savait pas donc moi j'ai jamais eu de
cas en deux ans jamais quelqu'un est
venu me voir
attention bien là le problème c'est
coloré on l'aurait soulevé on aurait été
au fond des choses
jamais personne
ça s'est passé c'est pas vrai et c'est
pour ça que je suis surpris aussi
quand j'entends certains athlètes qui
ont été nos grands champions bien
aujourd'hui 10 où il y avait des rumeurs
à willy sont contentes condamnable que
gailhaguet et pourquoi ils n'ont rien
fait c'est un scandale
mais une rumeur ces différentes
approches à gaillac et par exemple c'est
d'avoir les oreilles d'avoir eu les
infos c'est pas la même joie des fans
médaille et je dis encore une fois c'est
qu'il adore change pour ça c'est clair
je le connais mais là effectivement il
doit il doit parfait parce qu'elles
émanent commandes de sa fédération et il
en est le responsable penser qu'il a
déridé aujourd'hui moi je pas dit ça
devient aujourd'hui le cas gailhaguet
mais en dessous c'est parce que moi je
veux qu'on ait aujourd'hui le débit de
films et qu'on trouve des solutions pour
lever ce jour d'hui on parle que de lui
mais c'est pas ça le sujet non mais ça
lui il a manqué à ses devoirs il doit
partir thomas petit symptomatique du
système quand même c'est que par exemple
dans cette fédération de patinage quand
on est allé une première fois en justice
la fédération s'est pas porté partie
civile
vous vous raconter que dans votre
histoire vous vous êtes est partie
civile alors si je ne suis pas partie
civile comme ce qui me dérangeait la
cena soir c'est que il dit jamais il y
fait pas il averti la ministre marie
george buffet qui lie à nous elle
diligente une enquête est il des banshee
attendons les retours de le droit
d'aller travailler ces jeunes là ceux
qui ont donné la part la possibilité je
veux que cela s'explique qui sont
condamnables
comment commencer on en connaît le pays
du capteur de 2 de stopper son bâtiment
pour les revendre et je rebondis parce
qu'en fait l'enquète qu'on a fait avec
dispose pendant huit mois on a montré
que un cas sur deux qu'on a identifié
c'est la récidive
c'est ça un cas sur deux c'est à dire
que en fait il ya des alertes qui sont
donnés il ya parfois des types qui sont
condamnés et pourtant on les retrouve
dans des clubs parfois à l'autre bout de
la france et leurs erreurs leurs
antécédents judiciaires il donc par qui
les protège vous dites il ya un système
qui est qui bloque la libération la
parole en fait c'est très complexe mais
pour essayer d'être un tout petit peu
rapide la première chose c'est que les
clubs ne connaissent pas l'arsenal
juridique qui connaissent pas les lois
ils connaissent pas les îles ont pas ils
ne connaissent pas les outils auxquels
ils ont accès normalement c'est à dire
que par exemple il ya une loi dans le
code du sport qui interdit à une
personne condamnée d'être à nouveau au
contact du mineur et d'exercer dans un
club ça nous on a fait des interviews
avec temps plein de clubs amateurs
notamment dans le reportage en a
il connaît pas la loi donc il ne sait
pas que le type ne peut pas revenir dans
le match
d'où l'importance les fédérations
d'accompagner les que les clubs ce sont
des gens bénévoles effectivement qu'un
petit air de saint gilles mais quelle
catastrophe mots le premier ça va avec
la bouche et ça va très très bien sûr il
reconnaît l'avait eu peur ou bernard ont
pas peur manque et moi aussi moi chaque
fois comme lancôme qu'on m'appelle et
comme le dit bernard ya une caméra sus
une catastrophe et ouais peur non
aujourd'hui vous pouvez aujourd'hui vous
pouvez nous dire vous depuis que vous
êtes président de la fédération
française de rugby
vous pensez vous avez géré tous les cas
en tout cas xc60 ont certainement pas
parce qu'il est retardé certaines mains
des cas où personne n'a parlé on s'est
servi tous les cas là par contre ce qui
est sûr c'est que nous aujourd'hui on a
un numéro vert d'accord les clubs les
parents les licenciés peuvent appeler il
n'ya qu'une personne c'est la
responsable de la cohésion sociale à la
fédération dans ce derby il ya quelques
ils nous répondent à ce téléphone
mais effectivement si les gamins ne
parle pas donc vous dire on est bien sûr
c'est profitable dont je vous avais
entendu parler de vendre il moi j'ai une
question à vous poser parce que vous
avez fait une grande enquête et on a
l'impression quand on voit documentaire
qu'il va y avoir un séisme dans le sport
et que là on voit que la partie vraiment
une partie infime de ce qui va se passer
est ce que vous avez vous déjà des
informations est ce que vous pouvez nous
dire aller il va avoir dans le sport ça
va être là il va tout va plutôt vers
pédalage en fait depuis que l'on a
diffusé le documentaire avec le tout
l'enquêté sortie en décembre sur le site
donc disque aux points ngo on a récupéré
déjà une cinquantaine de témoignages
nouveau sur lequel on peut continuer à
enquêter donc en fait ça commence pas
mal à tomber
tout à l'heure vous entendez dans le
lancement vous disais que l' enquête
avait pas eu forcément le retentissement
qu'elle a aujourd'hui c'est évidemment
on est terrible terrifié d'entendre ce
qui s'est passé avec sarah abitbol en
même temps moi je me félicite de voir
que l'enquêté est là une deuxième vie
aujourd'hui quelques mois près sûr que
je pense rapidement qu'en gros on est à
un moment où c'est à la fois une sorte
de mythe ou du sport c'est à dire que on
sait que les paroles des victimes vont
être plus entendue donc les victimes
osent peut-être plus parler mais en même
temps je trouve qu'on s'inscrit aussi
dans la continuité de ce qui s'est aussi
passé dans l'église par exemple comme je
disais où les prêtres étaient déplacés
aujourd'hui on se rend compte que ça ça
ne peut plus exister
et au fur et à mesure à la fois les
victimes parlent les responsables se
rendent compte qu'il faut qu'ils soient
plus vigilants et forcément on espère
que à la fois les les histoires sorte
que les victimes aux enfants parlaient
que les prédateurs soient condamnés et
rico
soit pas là dans quelques années à dire
la même chose alors concrètement
montjoie ya plein de gens sur les
réseaux sociaux qu'ils disent oui mais
nous on a envie que nos enfants
continuent à faire du sport
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire comment on
peut essayer de douala de s'immuniser
contre ça est-ce qu'il faut discuter
avec les enfants qu'il faut faire parce
que tout le monde voilà sur les réseaux
sociaux disent voilà on veut absolument
que nos enfants fassent du sport mais si
à chaque fois qu'on les amène où à
chaque fois qu'on les envoie sage on se
dit j'espère qu'on va les avoir le soir
au téléphone et on va s'imaginer plein
de choses comment on fait oui j'en ai
bernard est ce que quand un entraîneur
se présente pour un pass est ce qu'il ya
une demande son casier judiciaire ou sk
une enquête de moralité sur lui pas
c'est une très bonne question
là c'est la même chose il faut ou à
partir de maintenant qu'un éducateur il
fournit son cas les initiants déjà qu'il
n'a pas eu d'antécédents
c'est la première des choses ça veut pas
dire qu'il ne fera pas une fois mais au
moins on est sûr que c'est pas une année
comme il le disait lui-même
et ça ça n'existe pas donc ça le numéro
vert libérer la parole effectivement
informé les clubs je dis bien informée
les clubs parce que souvent on en veut
au club
attention heureusement qu'ils sont là ce
sont des gens bénévoles qui donnent de
leur temps et c'est qu'ils n'ont pas
tous les toulonnais ont tous les
arguments et tout le temps la commission
fait un travail magnifique salissures et
jurent ils ont il faut les accompagner
c'est pour ça que colosse aux pieds
d'argile est une association qui fait ça
elle va dans les clubs elle une forme
non phil read more league mais bernard
bernard et et peut-être vendre il aussi
à des solutions parce qu'il a fait une
grande enquête et vos cibles sont là bas
parce que moi je vous dis la question
qu'on se pose c'est comment on fait est
ce qu'on en voit encore nos enfants
stage ou est ce qu'on se dit non on va
les chercher on les ramène et on leur
plus de stages on reste même aux séances
de sport comment ça se passe
oui j le sport français vous l'avez dit
bernard repose beaucoup sur le bénévolat
est formidable dans les chiottes par
tous les bénévoles est l'un des
problèmes c'est que on ne contrôle pas
les bénévoles
un bénévole il n'a pas présenté de
casier judiciaire il n'a pas à dire quel
était son parcours il n'a pas à se
justifier donc ça berlin est ce que vous
pensez qu'il faut instituer maintenant
où le contrôle des bénévoles
oui bien sûr parce que je fais des bons
éducateurs ou pas effectivement parce
que là ça s'appelle des entraîneurs ça
peut être aussi des dirigeants oui on
est à l'abri de rien donc effectivement
jeu ok je m'engage dans une zone clé
mais je dois justifier que je n'ai
jamais rien fait je pense aussi que les
parents fous qui parle aussi aux enfants
leur expliquer qu'il y avait ce qu'on
doit pas subir parce que c'est avec les
parents aux parents parlent que c'est un
peu tabou
moi mes enfants pas mon jour a expliqué
qu'il y avait des choses qui ne devait
pas subir ils n'auraient rien arriver
mais il était au courant qu'ils
pouvaient avoir des débordements des
caresses et qu'il fallait pas les
accepter
je pense que les parents doivent
vraiment parler aux enfants sans tabou
mais voilà si on te paie quelque chose
exprime toi tu dis le nous mais si c'est
très compliqué aujourd'hui j'espère que
les choses vont changer
mais bon oui c'est celle que c'est
compliqué parce que moi je suis ravi que
vous l'ayez invités passent commande
décembre j'avais été surprise du peu
d'impact de cette enquête
je pensais que ça allait faire et rien
brute rien vous expliquer ses surnoms
n'en parlait quand même bon alors il
peut quand même rires oui non mais je
pense qu'en fait c'est sûr que nous on
avait décidé d'avoir une approche très
systémique de raconter le système donc
c'est on est sur une approche très
quantitatif d'avoir beaucoup de chiffres
on a enquêté pendant des mois
c'est normal aussi que le fait que ce
soit sarah abitbol que ce soit une
championne multimédaillé c'est normal
qu'ils aient plus d'impact de toute
façon là le moment le seul le message
que j'ai par rapport à ça c'est que je
pense que les deux sont nécessaires à la
fois c'est bien qu'on ait fait cette
enquête systémique qui montre que ce
n'est pas un cas isolé
d'ailleurs je reviens juste sur les
excuses ou le la défense de gaillac et
quand il est sorti de ya quelques jours
là il sort de son bureau et il dit tout
de suite mais hier c'est un cas
particulier et en fait elle moi c'est le
truc qui me fait le plus tiquer c'est
pas un cas particulier
donc notre enquête à la fois le montre
ça aujourd'hui évidemment il ya sarah
abitbol qui par dessus donne une énorme
souffle à tout ça tant mieux enfin tant
mieux en tout cas pour les pour les
victimes pour qu'elles puissent parler
qu'elle comprenne que maintenant on est
à leur écoute